- I WANT TO KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH THE HUGE WOMAN,
AND I WANT TO KNOW
WHAT THE DEAL IS
WITH THE RED WITCH LADY.
- YES.
YES.
- [laughs]
I WOULD TOO.
- YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
- [laughing]
- STRAIGHT OUT.
- NO, BUT I MEAN, LIKE,
HAVE YOU?
HAVE YOU--HAVE YOU EVER
SLEPT WITH A BLACK GUY?
- NO, BUT I REALLY WANT TO.
[laughs]
- ME TOO!
APPARENTLY, IT IS, LIKE,
A WHOLE OTHER THING
THAN SLEEPING WITH WHITE MEN.
- OH, NO, NO.
I HEARD THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE, LIKE,
WAY BETTER AT IT
OR SOMETHING.
- YEAH. YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
I HEARD THAT TOO.
I WONDER IF IT'S
'CAUSE THEY HAVE,
LIKE--LIKE, BETTER RHYTHM,
YOU KNOW?
- RIGHT, 'CAUSE
THEY'RE REALLY GOOD DANCERS.
- I MEAN, APPARENTLY,
THEY HAVE, LIKE, BIGGER--
- OH, WAY BIGGER PENISES, RIGHT?
[laughs]
- YEAH.
I GUESS THAT'S
BECAUSE OF AFRICA?
- YEAH, LIKE,
I FEEL LIKE THEY'RE JUST--
THEY'RE, LIKE, REALLY
WITH YOU IN THE MOMENT.
- HMM.
- LIKE, IF THEY'RE GONNA
BE WITH YOU,
THEY'RE IN THE HERE AND NOW.
- EXACTLY. EXACTLY.
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT
THEY BASICALLY HAVE NO FUTURE.
- [laughs]
I KNOW.
- THINK ABOUT IT.
- IT'S SO SAD.
- THINK ABOUT IT!
[laughs]
- I DO FEEL LIKE THEY TREAT
THEIR WOMEN WITH JUST, LIKE,
A LITTLE BIT
MORE COMPASSION, THOUGH.
- YEAH,
LIKE, RESPECT AND STUFF.
OH, BECAUSE THEIR DADS
WERE NEVER AROUND!
- OH, RIGHT, AND THEY ALSO HAVE
A LOT OF TIME ON THEIR HANDS
'CAUSE EVEN IF THEY HAVE KIDS,
THEY NEVER GO VISIT THEM.
- OH, PLEASE. TOTALLY.
BABY DADDY?
THAT'S A THING.
- OH.
THAT'S IN THE DICTIONARY NOW
BECAUSE OF BLACK PEOPLE.
- SEE?
SER-I-OU-SLY.
APPARENTLY, BLACK GUYS JUST KNOW
HOW TO PLEASE WHITE WOMEN.
RIGHT? JUST, LIKE,
WAY MORE THAN WHITE MEN.
- OH, WELL, IT'S PROBABLY
IN THEIR BLOOD
'CAUSE THEY'RE USED
TO PLEASING THEIR WHITE MASTERS.
- WHAAAT?
- OKAY. OKAY.
- YEAH!
LAW OF THE JUNGLE, RIGHT?
- [laughs] TOTALLY.
- I AM SO DESPERATE
TO FIND OUT FOR MYSELF.
[laughter]
- ME TOO.
- RIGHT?
- OKAY, UM, I'M GONNA
GO TO THE BATHROOM...
- OKAY.
- AND I SWEAR TO YOU,
IF THERE IS A BLACK GUY
BACK THERE, I'M GONNA BLOW HIM.
[laughter]
- GET IT!
- SO, UNRELATED, I NOW
HAVE TO GO TO THE BATHROOM,
UH, BECAUSE I'VE BEEN
DRINKING COFFEE ALL DAY.
SO I WILL BE BACK
IN A LITTLE WHILE.
- WELL, YOU KNOW WHAT?
LET--LET ME GO FIRST.
I'LL BE ABOUT 30 SECONDS.
- OOH, OW.
I HIT MY PENIS THERE.
- I'M SORRY.
I DON'T HAVE ANY MONEY, SIR.
- OKAY.